are we what are we doing yeah are there
any more questions are we about to wrap
this up this is
two and a half hours i got a question
yeah i got a couple more
ben rod johansson spin rod can they repo
your plastic surgery and make your hair
go back to the old days that's
that's nice that's nice
somebody hey somebody wrote a question
you can't do them like that that's
[ __ ] up someone wrote a question
asking about um would i do
any more plastic surgery and what would
i do did you see that question yeah we
asked you that in the last podcast
and you said you'd get hair grafts done
again i'd get i get more i just get more
yeah my hair see through it's too thin
but that's crazy how they [ __ ]
slice the back of your head
it looks pretty good sitting right next
to you well i mean i appreciate it still
it needs to be thicker
and you have like no gray hair at all
you have like zero kid i have tons of
gray hair yeah you have a few in the
corners i guess
yeah not much considering you're what
how old are you 50. 50.
50. looking straight 50 years old
gentlemen so 50 and i would get i think
i'd get liposuction again
really yeah where did you get lego yeah
where the [ __ ] just and
you know i just like a little tighten up
and i like to get that like i get
i like to get my jawline down a little
bit look
a little little from behind the ears get
the you know tightening like a little
wet vac under
yeah a little little yeah a little they
they take a a
i think they take a thing and they they
like a straw and they
and they suck yeah like they look like
like cheese thing that they put in your
mouth yeah like cheese
you know they stick in it sucks it out
and you push the cheese down you just
you know
do you get to keep the cheese when they
suck it out i i didn't i didn't inquire
about the cheese
but you saw um you saw a
fight club where they were taking the
body fat yeah they were making soap out
of it
it's nice to have a bar soap made of
like me you could call like me
be like that's that's there's something
for plastic surgeons
there's some merch yeah matt cox the fat
bag
soap [ __ ] fat bag fast or soap
fat soap fat would anybody would anybody
listening
buy a bag of backpacks
i thought we were going to make it into
soap fat coffee
i was thinking of basketball when he's
drinking a bag of fat when he's trying
to psych somebody out but
the soap makes much more sense for
shipping of course
you can't ship a bag of fat you can make
too hard chips and bars
you want some soap leave a comment
oh my god have we run our course i mean
it's
it's oh you know i can keep talking yeah
i'll talk forever
you want to talk about it i tell you
what you know
i buy a book that's now that we have
some downtime like i have books on
amazon you can buy a book it's cheap
it's a pretty good book
it's pretty good it's a [ __ ] great
book bro yeah it's a great book
you wouldn't know you don't read don't
forget
it's uh it's it's definitely definitely
buy a book we got
and gotta join the channel inside true
crime i got a whole bunch of my stories
on
um their podcast right that's podcast
right they're
they're narrated and audiobooks whatever
working on some stuff i got i got uh
got stuff going matt what was what was
the most favorite part of the whole
the whole deal the whole shebang the
whole crime spree
what was like the the one time you're
like kicking back you're like
this is it this is the omega peak level
right here this is you know you're gonna
be hard you're
not i didn't i sell this when you were
you were like overseas right
on a yacht okay you remember yeah yeah
yeah
it was on a cruise ship it wasn't a
yacht it was a cruise ship and we were
in our country
yeah it was a cruise ship and i remember
in greece
yeah we were going through the um
mediterranean sea
and we had been to greece we went to
greece we went to
italy and we went to croatia we were
going through the mediterranean
and we were laying out
on the top deck and i remember the
waiters bringing us
you know drinks i remember i looked over
the girl i was dating she was like 25
26 years old and just and you were what
like 35
37 just just was like a month or so
smoking hot smoke and i remember she
looked over at me and i remember she
lipped
she said she said i love you and i
looked at it i remember thinking
[ __ ] no matter what happens this moment
is worth it i mean i got a ton of money
in the bank i'm
got a 26 year old chick i mean
everything's got i'm a mediterranean
mediterranean sea i'm on his [ __ ]
cruise this is it
this this is this is amazing no matter
what this moment is worth it this is it
and i was absolutely wrong about that
you felt like jordan bell i felt great
at that moment but listen
when the after then when the judge
sentenced me i was like [ __ ] that
not worth it not sure what i was
thinking in that moment
wasn't thinking rationally yeah
because she's not calling you no no i
never heard her where's she i got a
letter
oh yeah did she out did you do you give
her a credit card she ever owned a
credit card
uh bro i had paid for everything for her
yeah you paid for everything yeah i mean
i
i bought her a car i actually bought her
a couple cars
um yeah paid off all of her bills when
we met paid off everything her whatever
bills she's running up or
just paying and i put money in her i
mean you know
you know it's a look it's all stolen
money anyway
right so you know it spins like it's
ridiculous
didn't you say uh jordan belfort wanted
you on his podcast
no the wolf of wall street i sent um
the guy from valuetainment they gave me
his information and said
to contact him and say that i should be
on his podcast
i traded a couple emails with his
assistant
and the whole corona thing happened just
like the thing with um blumhouse
the production company yeah i was
supposed to fly out to los angeles
on the 21st of last month because they
want to talk to me about doing a series
and we were supposed to fly out there
and meet with them for like
two or three hours and meet everybody
and sit down and talk about the series
and then the corona thing happened so
they didn't fly anybody out they're like
not flying anybody out right right and
so then we've we've swapped some emails
and i've talked to
danny rothbart is the guy who's uh
with me on the project okay and so i've
talked to him the last couple days and
supposedly they want to put together
some
kind of skype in the next next week and
then hopefully in
a month when everything kind of opens
back up whatever i'm supposed to fly in
and talk to them
so we'll see what happens with that
blumhouse is huge they did like
paranormal activity what else do they do
what are their movies
get out they get out yeah they just did
the invisible man
you know um handmaid's tale they do that
they've got a bunch of they got like
four series i think on hulu and
and uh and so we've had multiple
discussions
about wanting to do a series where i'm
in prison
i like the fact that they do a lot of
like smaller independent type movies
handmade still sick do they
yeah handmade stales great right and
that grew
oh it is so good though it is it's
so creepy yeah uh oh you gotta you gotta
watch that you can't you watch
like one or two episodes that's it it's
over you're just binging on it for the
next week straight
handmaid's tale that's why i try not to
watch any of those programs yeah they
get you hooked on yeah
they're made to watch them all at once
can't just watch one how long are the
episodes like an hour 45 minutes
yeah it's good i've been watching the uh
the michael jordan documentary that's
all i've been watching lately
you love talking there's pretty good
it's a serious documentary series 10
parts
you haven't seen any of it that's good i
try not to watch tv
no i tried like i got sucked into ozarks
the other day
oh i watched that soon next two weeks
just every night two hours
y'all watch waco no that was good yeah
watch that
that was [ __ ] sick i didn't watch
that i just watched it
waco about that uh
but they flip it and they tell the story
from inside the church rather from like
the
the fbi point of view atf point of view
that you hear in the news yeah yeah it's
like about the guy who met who runs the
call yeah david koresh
yes yeah he's good he was crazy
yeah he was out there they really focus
on his guitar playing in it which i
really appreciate
the guitars everywhere he did throw up
some acoustic shreds
yeah there was a scene where he was
getting married and while his brides
were walking towards him he was playing
here comes the bride on like a sick
flying v
hell yeah one of the best wedding scenes
did you watch the tiger king
i watched one i think i watched two
episodes i've been saying i watched one
episode but actually the more i think
about it i think i watched two episodes
yeah i just couldn't do it no
everybody's telling me you got to watch
it it's amazing well i mean i watched
two episodes and it's just
i mean and i'm not i'm not just
continues to get crazier it's just
straight white trash
it's just a straight dress it's just
insanity
[ __ ] but i don't
i mean i grew up in florida you know
down the street from a trailer park
so i mean it was you know we were middle
class but there was a trailer park so i
mean i
i've been close enough to all the
insanity of just
you know drunks and people running
around with bare feet and
they got [ __ ] wrestling tigers and
all that crazy
i love i love ozone ozarks is good it's
great it's great
and i get all these people that keep
telling me that like i got friends that
will call me
i've had five friends that have called
me like you know have you seen ozarks
somebody just dropped a hundred bucks
[Laughter]
but you gotta drink up some crab juice
that's what i'm talking about i swear
wow pray you want to see it on god
give matt some of this to put towards
his restitution or at least buy him a
few
there you go a few what danny you gotta
do
you left out the last sentence that says
danny
you gotta drink it
some selective reading drink the crab
drink the crab
drink the crab drink the oh
he's drinking the ground crab
this is the only kind of stuff that
you're going to see on concrete
because that's good juice oh i don't
waste that juice boy that's
good oh it's not terrible
it's like butter and gravy this is the
best night of my life garlic and old
days
[ __ ] hell yeah
he's gonna feel that one later it's like
viagra it's gonna go in one yeah
true it might light a fire up on you oh
there's this is a repeating question but
people
keep paying to see it they want to know
about the best fraud story
i know you've already told it tonight
but just give a quick little rundown of
it
what's this what's the best modern day
fraud there's any kind of fraud
what kind of fraud would you commit now
or like a fraud that you've looked at
[Laughter]
yeah he's saving that that's that one's
going behind the paywall of inside true
crime
that's for the next episode that's right
matt cox who thinks matt cox should have
his only fan and only fans yeah drop a
eggplant emoji if you think matt cox
should certain only fans
you know how many guys in prison we
would talk to because like the frog guys
always find each other
and i've talked to fraud guys and like
they'll come and i'm like well what'd
you do and they're like i did this and
this and this and
and you're like okay okay well
why did you do that and then you start
talking i'm like well why didn't you do
this did you ever think about this and
they're like that right and then they're
like
[ __ ] i didn't even think about that and
they're like man
you know then they start thinking a new
one oh let's do it we would spend
and i don't mean spending i don't mean
to spend an hour or two i'm talking
about
two or three hours a day yeah for months
yeah
and you're perfect i mean to the point
where you're like how do you get around
that
how do you the big thing is how do you
get notified
that the fbi or whoever secret service
fbi
they picked up on you that they've
they've picked up on the fraud
how do you get t you know how do you get
that how do you get tipped off
yeah and so i mean we got to the point
where like here's what you do
and you start because here's what
they're going to here's how they're
going to start the investigation
so they're going to do this the first
thing they're going to do is they're
going to go here well if you're that
person
they'll contact you and say look it's
fbi or they'll walk in or
i mean we've literally laid out there
i'm there's got to be like four
different ones where we had just
you're so bored right and you've got
picture perfect you know how many times
you would meet somebody that i would
meet somebody who's
had that well how'd you get your money
oh i would transfer to bitcoins i would
do this i would buy gold i would do this
and you so now it's like okay well now i
have another tool that i didn't have
before
and then you would say well do you ever
think about doing that next thing you
know man it's it's
there are there are some scams that
you're just like
a lot of these guys would do scams in
their own names or they would
it would just what are those those are
eggplants
like plants oh my gosh they weren't only
fans that's people who aren't
doing only fans oh there's a ton of
eggplants
yeah the demand is there so the market
is there it's all about supply and
demand you gotta strike while the
eggplant is hot moment
[Laughter]